KELLY BAILEY: Welcome, everyone.
Thanks for coming out.
I'm Kelly Bailey.
I'm a recruiter in the
JTAG organization here.
So I'm really, really excited
to be here to introduce Emily.
So she is an author.
And she specializes in
science and culture.
Her stories have been featured
in a variety of publications,
like the "New York Times" and a
couple of my favorite podcasts,
like "This American
Life" and "RadioLab."
And she is also a recipient
of the Pulitzer Traveling
Fellowship, which,
I think, allowed you
to travel and
research for the book
that you're here to
talk about, today,
"The Dragon Behind The Glass."
So welcome.
Thank you for joining us.
EMILY VOIGT: Thank you
so much for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
KELLY BAILEY: I know yesterday
was the official release.
EMILY VOIGT: Yeah, that's right.
KELLY BAILEY: How'd it go?
EMILY VOIGT: It was good.
It was really exciting
to finally see it out.
It's been a long time coming.
So yeah.
It was really, really exciting.
KELLY BAILEY: Well,
congratulations.
EMILY VOIGT: Thank you.
KELLY BAILEY: Thank
you for taking time out
of your busy schedule.
I know you just had a little
one, too-- so super busy.
But would you like to give
us all a quick summary
of what your inspiration
was for the book?
EMILY VOIGT: Yeah.
So I thought I would just start
by telling people how I first
heard about this fish,
the Asian arowana
that "The Dragon Behind
The Glass" was about.
It was back in 2009--
so seven years ago.
I was doing a radio story
about the exotic pet trade
in New York City.
And I went with a pet
detective up to the South Bronx
to investigate reports
of an alligator there.
Guy was offering an alligator
for sale on Craigslist.
KELLY BAILEY: It's normal.
EMILY VOIGT: It was a big
bust in a housing project
and everything.
But we didn't find
the alligator.
So I was pretty disappointed.
But he kept telling me about
these illegal super expensive
fish that were being smuggled
into the city from Southeast
Asia.
And he said that they
were considered good luck
in certain cultures.
They were thought
to bring prosperity.
And for that reason, they
had been over harvested
from the wild and were
commanding these high prices.
They were protected by the
US Endangered Species Act,
so you can't bring them across
the border of the United States
legally as a pet.
So anyway, actually
I was totally not
thrilled to hear this
because I was hoping
to find some kind of huge
animal that you wouldn't expect
to find in the
city for my story.
So I kept trying to
steer him away from fish.
But then I got home and I kept
thinking about-- he told me
that this one Wall Street
banker had broken down
in tears when he had his illegal
fish confiscated from him.
This is pretty wacky.
I wonder what would make
somebody so compelled
to own a species that they would
take such risk-- because people
actually go to prison
for this in some cases.
So I looked up the species.
And I started doing
some research.
And I was just absolutely
astounded by what I found.
So I thought what I
would do is start off
with a very short reading
from the book explaining
what happened after I got home
from that failed alligator
bust.
So this is what I read.
"Forget oil and diamonds.
The next big thing in
Southeast Asia is fish,
I read in the hobbyist
magazine, Practical Fishkeeping,
which described how 50
specimens, collectively valued
at $1 million had been placed
under 24 hour guard in Jakarta,
Indonesia.
While these fish may be
disappearing from the wild,
their popularity amongst Asia's
richest is ever increasing.
In some instances,
the species was
reared on farms that could
pass as prisons, facilities
protected by nested walls,
watchtowers, and rottweilers
that prowl the
perimeter at night.
The reason for
the heavy security
became clear as I dug deeper
into the international news
archive that chronicled
a spate of fish thefts
across Southeast Asia.
In Malaysia, five arowana
stolen from a woman's house
were worth more than all her
other possessions combined.
Singapore, which boasts
one of the lowest crime
rates in the world, once
reported four such heists
in a single week.
One thief punched
out an elderly woman
who chased him as he made
off with a prized fish
in a sloshing bucket.
He was sentenced to
three years in prison
and 12 strokes of a wet cane.
As for who was
taking the fish, some
surmised that thieves were
fish lovers who could not
afford the astronomical prices.
Others suspected that
a crime syndicate
was behind the thefts, a
sort of shadowy fish mafia.
Bolstering this theory was a
harrowing case in Indonesia
where an arowana dealer and
his heavily armed cronies
allegedly kidnapped and held
for ransom a Japanese buyer.
Despite all this
criminality, however,
the trade in the farmed fish
was legal, not only in Asia,
but throughout
most of the world,
including Canada and Europe.
The one major exception,
other than the United States,
being Australia which
bans the species
to protect its own
tropical fauna.
A few years back, a
45-year-old housewife
was arrested at the
Melbourne airport trying
to enter the country
with 51 fish,
including an Asian arowana
hidden beneath her poofy skirt.
'We became suspicious after
hearing these flipping
and flapping noises,' a customs
officials later told the press.
Such absurd tales
of smuggling kept me
up late as I pored
through the 100
some articles I'd printed out
and spread across my living
room floor.
The picture that
gradually emerged,
however, looked less like
the illegal drug trade
and more like a parody of
Manhattan's overheated art
scene, complete
with record breaking
prices, anonymous
buyers, stolen specimens,
unsavory dealers, and
even clever fakes.
Whatever the best
metaphor, it seemed
the Asian arowana had a long
history of driving human beings
to dangerous extremes.
One summer in college,
I read Jane Goodall's
"In the Shadow of
Man," and ever since, I
dreamed of venturing
into the jungle
to write a great
story about wildlife.
Around the time my curiosity
in the arowana began,
I've been awarded a fellowship
intended to fund a reporting
project abroad.
Now, I knew how I'd use it.
I would go see for myself where
all these smuggled arowana were
coming from and what made
the species so irresistible.
Goodall had her noble
tool wielding primates.
I would have the bad
tempered, bony tongued fish.
It was obvious where to start.
At the center of
the glamorous world
of Southeast Asian
aquaculture reigned
a flamboyant Singaporean
tastemaker known as Kenny
the Fish, a chain
smoking millionaire
fond of posing nude behind
strategically placed
aquatic pets.
[LAUGHTER]
The Fish's real
name was Kenny Yap.
And he was the executive
chairman of an ornamental fish
farm so lucrative that it
was listed on Singapore's
main stock exchange.
Recently, the Singaporean
press had dubbed him
one of the city's most
eligible bachelor's
and called for him to host a
national spin of Donald Trump's
reality show, "The Apprentice."
To enter his website, I had
to click on his belly button.
I've since come to think of
this navel as the rabbit hole
into which I fell not to
emerge from some three
and a half years."
KELLY BAILEY: Oh, my gosh.
I'm not going to lie.
When I first started
reading this book,
I thought it was fiction because
this Kenny the Fish character
sounded so outlandish.
He sounds like he's straight
out of "The Godfather."
So could you tell us what your
expectations and impressions
were-- because you actually
had the opportunity
to see him in his natural
environment and meet him?
So what were your impressions?
EMILY VOIGT: Right.
In his natural habitat.
KELLY BAILEY: In
his natural habitat.
EMILY VOIGT: So Kenny really
drew me into the story.
And I was thinking back on it.
And for me, he's a little
bit like the Wizard
in The Wizard of Oz.
So I kind of started with him.
And then I went off on
this strange adventure.
But he was always kind of
the man behind the curtain.
There was this
glamorous world that I
was trying to get behind.
KELLY BAILEY: Totally.
EMILY VOIGT: And he represented
the public face of that.
Singapore actually
exports more pet fish
than any other
country in the world
so that it makes sense
that I would start there.
And he's kind of like the
kingpin of this industry.
They used to be famous--
it's been true of a long time
that Singapore is
the hub of the trade.
But they used to be
famous for guppies.
They were called guppy kingdom.
And I mean-- the guppy
versus inverse the arowana.
Big difference.
KELLY BAILEY: Little bit.
EMILY VOIGT: Yeah, not
just in size-- the guppy
is like this big and the
arowana is pretty huge--
but also in price, and
mystique, and so forth.
So Kenny had come
along at a point where
there was a sexy make over
of the ornamental fish trade,
a very traditional trade.
And he knew how to give
it this exciting new face.
And he has a very
carefully crafted image.
So for example, he came
up with his own nickname,
Kenny the Fish.
And he was actually-- he told
me was getting a passport
photo taken when he
was suddenly inspired
to strip down to a g-string
and just pose with a fish.
KELLY BAILEY: That's normal.
I think we've all been there.
We've all been there.
EMILY VOIGT: Right, right.
So I'm sure that the
photographer was surprised,
but probably also thrilled.
So he definitely
represented a lot of color.
He calls himself naughty a lot.
So he would say,
I'm just naughty.
I'm just playful and naughty.
But the truth is-- but it's all
in this very innocent fun way--
And sort of shiny,
happy, smiley way.
I say, he always has a practiced
expression of ecstatic delight
because his face is
plastered everywhere,
not just on his farm, but
also throughout Singapore.
And so my associate, he's
a bit of a celebrity.
So he's always just
beaming in ecstasy.
But when I asked
him about-- and so
he offered me this
wonderful entry point
into the world of the arowana.
But when I asked
him about-- well,
what about all these fish
robberies that I read about.
He was like, what
fish robberies?
I didn't think the answer.
So it was always this weird
tension between the fact
that the fish hobby is--
pet fish themselves.
They're these very
innocent things.
We associate them
with childhood.
And the hobby itself is very
educational and kind of sweet.
There was this
tension between that.
And then the fact that there
was indeed a darker side
to the trade.
And there is a genuine
sense of menace
that's connected with this.
So for example, a Malaysian
member of parliament,
while I was reporting on
this, received a text message
with a dead arowana.
And they took it seriously
as a death threat.
KELLY BAILEY: Oh, my gosh.
EMILY VOIGT: And
actually, even stranger,
while I was reporting on this,
the head of the Indonesian
national police, the Chief
Detective of the Indonesian
National Police, which is
the equivalent of the FBI,
was brought down by the fish.
So he landed in
prison over a bribe
that he had taken related
to one of these fish farms.
So it just always
seemed like the fish was
connected to very high places.
And you can never quite
tell what was true.
I talked to one of these farms.
It took me a while
to find a farm that
was willing to talk about some
of the fish robberies that
were going on.
Some were reported in the press.
But largely, people would say
that they hadn't heard of it.
And finally, I
found this guy who
said he had been robbed eight
times in the last decade.
So he had been tied up.
And there were just
bandits coming and taking
the fish in the night.
And nobody was quite sure who
was behind it and so forth.
So that kind of thing.
And there were rumors even
of fish related murders.
And it took me a very long
time to pin down whether there
is any truth to that.
KELLY BAILEY: Yeah, I'm sure.
And with a character like Kenny
the Fish, where do you start?
So Kenny the Fish isn't
the only very outlandish--
I want to say character.
But they're real
people in this book.
So I do feel like
sometimes just the lines
between fiction and nonfiction--
I was constantly confused.
But as you were writing
the book, what would
you say were some of
your greatest challenges
when you were
researching and meeting
these different
characters and people,
looking for the arowana?
EMILY VOIGT: So you talk about
how outlandish the world is.
And so the whole book is
definitely nonfiction.
And so because I was
doing a nonfiction book,
I really needed to know
what the truth was.
And it's definitely a
smoke and mirrors world.
So separating myth
from reality was
one of the biggest challenges.
It took a long time
in some instances.
So one of the first things
that I wanted to find out
was that-- so the
fish actually-- it's
a lot like the art market.
As I said before--
most of the fish
sell when they're about the size
of a finger, when they're just
babies.
And they sell for maybe
like $1,000-- $2,000.
But it goes up from there.
And it depends on all kinds
of very particular details
of the fish.
Like it's finnage-- which is
not a word I used to use a lot.
And its scales, the
shape of its eye.
And it's personality.
You want a fish that's
pretty aggressive.
You don't want one
that's nice, apparently.
Basically, the highest recorded
prices were in the six figures.
But it was always
an anonymous buyer--
like some anonymous
Japanese man who
bought this fish for $150,000.
And you're like, did
that really happen?
Is that just some kind of--
so I was really, really
determined to get
to the bottom of it.
And I attended-- so when I
went to meet Kenny the Fish,
I was incredibly fortunate.
It was a really opportune moment
to have landed in Singapore
because Aquarama was going on.
Aquarama is-- it's
this huge event.
It's the Westminster
Dog Show of pet fish.
So little show fish show
up in their plastic baggies
and compete for top prizes.
But the arowana are, by far, the
star attraction of this show.
So when I was there, the biggest
thing that happened that year
were that there were
these 10 albino arowanas.
As albinos were the ones
that sold for the most money,
historically.
But they would appear
on the market--
I don't know-- it was like a
rare Vermeer coming to light.
But this was like-- all of a
sudden, there are 10 of them.
Nobody knew where they came
from, or who owned them,
or what was going on.
So I tracked down the
guy who had bred them.
And it was this crazy story
about this Indonesian coal
tycoon who was
crazy about albinos.
And he had a zoo in Borneo
that was just albino animals.
And so word that came to
him of birth of an albino
at one of these farms.
And he traveled to the see it.
He stared at the fish all night.
And then he said to the farmer,
you must stop selling fish.
And then he started-- it
was this long seven year
period of breeding
them, and then breeding
the offspring with each other.
And eventually, they
bred these albinos.
So the idea was
that they were just
going to sell them to
celebrities and royalty-- one
to each country.
Reminded me of the golden
tickets in "Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory."
And so he told me the Sultan
of Johor had bought one.
A high ranking member of
the Chinese Communist Party
had bought a fish, supposedly,
for he said, $300,000.
KELLY BAILEY: Oh, my gosh.
EMILY VOIGT: So I
was like, I have
to meet one of these people.
I wasn't willing to
believe that it was true.
So he actually
arranged for me to go
meet the guy who had bought
one of these fish in Taiwan.
He was a plastics magnate who
made his fortune manufacturing
toothbrush bristles of all
things and barbie hair.
And when you think about
it, they're very similar.
So he made all this money off
of his toothbrush bristles.
And he spent $150,000 on
his fish, according to him.
It's like the art market.
There's no downside to saying
that you paid a certain amount.
So both the dealer and
the buyer will sometimes
inflate the prices.
But I do believe they
sell for a lot of money--
whatever the exact
figure may be.
KELLY BAILEY: I still
can't wrap my mind
around how much some of the
fish in the book that you were
describing were being sold for.
So speaking of the arowana--
you guys have seen the cover.
This is the arowana.
It is really dramatic.
When I first picked up the
book, I was like, what is this?
Is it actually a fish?
I thought it was a dragon--
like, legitimately.
What would you say are--
well, first, I guess,
is this the actual
super red arowana
that you were looking for?
And then how did you go about
choosing this particular image?
How did you choose
this for the cover?
EMILY VOIGT: Well, I agree.
I love the cover.
So the publisher did that.
Scribner did that.
And they did a beautiful job.
I think they did a gorgeous job.
KELLY BAILEY: Yeah,
it's beautiful.
EMILY VOIGT: But it is the
super red-- which nobody in here
knows what we're talking about.
So arowana-- I should also
just back up for a second
and explain that it's
a family of fish.
So there's seven species across
the tropics of the globe.
And the really expensive
one is the Asian arowana.
That's also the
most endangered one.
And it comes in these
different color varieties.
Because of the islands
throughout Southeast Asia,
you have different
populations that have evolved
in these different landmasses.
So there's three main
ones, green, gold, and red.
Green-- psh-- forget about it.
You don't want a green one.
I'm not sure why.
But gold and red
are very valuable.
Gold is sort of a
more recent-- it's
more popular more recently.
But the classic one is this
fish called the super red.
And it comes from a single lake
system in the heart of Borneo.
And I actually
became-- so I wanted
to know if the fish still
existed in the wild.
And I became somewhat
obsessed with it,
especially beginning
on that first trip when
I had gone over to
Singapore because I was
hearing all kinds of things.
Oh, yeah-- they're still there.
They're in the heart of Borneo.
It's fine.
The population is
doing really well.
Other people say
it's totally gone.
It doesn't exist anymore.
So I was like, OK,
I'm going to find out.
So I end up canceling
my flight home
after I went to see the
Taiwanese toothbrush bristle
tycoon.
And I flew back to Borneo
to try to get there.
And basically, I ended
up knee deep in a swamp
realizing I have no
idea how to do this.
How do you know if
a fish is there?
It took me so long
to get to the swamp.
And then it's like black water.
So you can't even see into it.
And I had never been
fishing a day in my life.
I didn't speak the language.
I went home, and I felt
like a total failure.
So I felt like I
had failed at that.
And I kept thinking
about this man who I felt
could have helped me.
He was the one who I
had met at Aquarama.
He's a superstar
in the fish world.
His name is Heiko Bleher.
He's a German
ichthyological explorer.
In fact, he is a
third generation
German ichthyological explorer.
So his grandfather had one of
the biggest ornamental fish
farms in the world in 1900,
at the turn of the century
in Frankfurt.
And then his mother took
him and his three siblings-
so her four children to
the Amazon rain forest
to another uncharted
section of the Amazon,
which is still pretty wild
today-- but in the 1950s.
This was just
completely unheard of.
He was seven years old.
She took them to go
find what was then
the most expensive
pet fish in the world.
It was a fish called
the discus, which
is this perfectly
round fish that
looks like the Greek discus.
So she went in search of
this elusive discus fish.
And then they got lost.
And they ended up living
among cannibals for two years.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
So I was like, huh?
So Heiko Bleher.
Since then, he had
basically never stopped
in the manic pursuit
of new species.
I mean, he was just
all over the world.
I would run into him
and he would say,
I've been to Tajikistan
and Australia.
He was just everywhere all the
time, constantly traveling.
He was kind of like
the Jacques Cousteau
of freshwater or something.
So I started thinking
about this man
and thinking that he was the
one who could have helped me.
And the book came about
when he looked me up
when he came through New York.
And I just got this
idea that the two of us
would go find this
fish in Borneo.
And that would be
how the story went.
And of course, you know
that it took many twists
and turns that I
had not expected.
KELLY BAILEY: Yeah.
I mean everyone
should read this book.
It was absurdly, absurdly--
I was at the edge of my seat.
EMILY VOIGT: Thank you.
KELLY BAILEY: So
I guess-- I was--
get you to pivot a little.
I was surprised going
through the book--
I was expecting an Indiana
Jones pursuit of this arowana.
But what kind of struck me was
how much conservation came up
throughout the-- I just feel
like notes of conservation
and just the environment
came up throughout the book.
And you explain, at some
point, that because of supply
and demand, there's
these fish farms.
And they're breeding these
arowana and other rare fish,
which may be causing
a negative effect
with the natural
wild population.
And I thought that was
just very surprising
and something I hadn't
really thought of before.
What would you say are a
few of the surprising things
that you've learned
while writing
"Dragon Behind The Glass"?
EMILY VOIGT: So one of the
first surprising things
I learned came right out
of the mouth of Kenny
the Fish when I
landed in Singapore.
I was talking to him about
what made the fish so valuable.
And I thought he was going to
talk about Feng Shui and all
these-- some kind of ancient
Chinese tradition basically.
And he didn't.
He was just talking about some
treaty that's administered
by the United Nations.
And that the fish is on it.
And I didn't put it
all together at first.
But basically, I
thought that there
would be this deep history to
this fish in Asian cultures.
And there simply wasn't.
Just a few decades back,
people were eating this.
This was what you ate
for dinner in the swamp.
And it wasn't even
a good food fish.
That's kind of an aside.
But people complained it's
kind of bony and bland.
In the 60s, southeast Asia was
losing a lot of its jungles
to development.
And at the same time-- this fish
is-- it's a very large fish.
It's an apex predator.
And it's a slow reproducer.
Some of them can take up
to six years to reproduce.
So the populations
were dwindling.
And it was right
at the time that
the international community
was trying to figure out
how we could organize the
trade in animals and threatened
animals so that we could get our
act together and protect them
from the international trade.
And it's almost as a fluke
that this fish ended up
as a test case in conservation.
It got put on this
list called CITES,
which is now one of the
largest conservation
agreements in the world.
But at the time,
it was brand new.
It was put on
appendix 1, which is
like the rarest of
the rare species.
And it was subject to an
international trade ban.
And very soon thereafter, it
became this coveted commodity.
Now, it's very difficult to
prove causality vs correlation.
But what I can say is it
just was not a phenomenon
until it had this
official stamp of rarity.
And that now conservation
biologists-- some of them,
have looked and said
that, in fact, you
do have to be careful about
the perception of rarity
and when you're declaring
an animal in danger
that it doesn't suddenly spike
its price on the black market.
But it's interesting,
too, looking
at this fish-- it really is an
encapsulation of the history
of conservation-- the modern
history of conservation
because, originally, the idea
was just to ban everything.
That was what we
started out by doing.
And then gradually, there was a
move towards sustainable trade.
So the example that's
often given-- and I talk
about it a little
bit in the book--
is crocodilians--
crocodiles and alligators.
They were pushed to the
brink of extinction--
a huge number of
the species on Earth
were just in a terrible
way after World War
II because they're is so much
demand for crocodile leather.
And then, they tried banning
it-- banning the trade
in crocodilians.
It didn't really work.
What worked was ranching them.
So you basically would go
into their natural habitat,
collect some eggs, raise
them on these farms,
and then sell their skins.
And this was probably the
greatest conservation success
story of the last quarter
of the 20th century.
And for that reason-- when
the arowana was in a bad way--
the Asian arowana--
in the 90s, they
tried doing the
same thing with it.
So they had this farming
program that arose.
But there's a difference between
ranching an animal, where
you have a connection
with the wild population,
and farming an
animal, where it's
a closed system and the
whole life cycle of the fish
is within the walls of a farm.
So very rapidly, you start
to domesticate the creature.
That's one issue.
And the other is that
there's no value placed
on preserving the wild habitat.
Some people still think
that it's a good way
to go for certain
threatened species.
And I would say to take it
on a case by case basis.
But people who
oppose it-- they say
it's because it creates a market
where there wasn't one before.
So after CITES came in
and started these farming
programs-- so when you buy
the fish on the legal market,
it has a little
microchip in it that
shows that it comes
from a certified farm.
There's a rigorous
certification process.
So they're not coming from
the wild for the most part.
They really are farmed.
But it created this
huge-- I call it
a mass produced endangered
species because, now, it's
just everywhere.
It's been sold-- more
than a million of them
have moved that we know of.
And so far, they're
trapped between borders.
But probably many more
because that doesn't take into
account the markets
within the countries
that actually produce them.
KELLY BAILEY: Sure.
So I guess you kind of touched
on it a little bit already.
But I was wondering if there
were any key takeaways that you
were hoping, in relation
to the environment,
that you're trying to get
across to your readers.
EMILY VOIGT: When I set
out to write this book,
I didn't want to write a
book about the environment.
I was really attracted
to-- I don't think it
says something great about me.
But I was attracted
to the ridiculousness
of the story and the humor and
high drama of the fish world.
And the old lady getting
punched out for her fish.
I was very into that.
But the truth is,
you really can't
write about the
arowana or any fish,
I think, today,
without coming face
to face with an
enormous amount of loss.
And this is particularly
true of freshwater fish.
So a lot of times when we
talk about the state of fish
today, people tend to focus
on marine species, especially
big ones like the tuna.
And the tuna is not doing well.
So I don't mean to
suggest that tunas are OK.
But the truth is
that marine fishes
are in much better shape
than freshwater fishes.
Freshwater is 2.5%
of the earth's water.
And then-- you might
have heard this before--
but then available
freshwater-- so
surface freshwater, freshwater
that's not frozen or buried
deep beneath the ground.
That's one hundredth of
1% of the Earth's water.
And it actually
supports nearly half
of the world's fish species.
So there are about 30,000
fish that are known today.
And nearly half of them
live in freshwater.
And the reason for that is
that it kind of functions
like islands.
It's like aquatic islands.
So the same reason
that islands tend
to be hotbeds of speciation--
same thing with freshwaters.
And so it's really a crucible
of the Earth's biodiversity.
And these are incredibly
vulnerable habitats.
We've done just a terrible
job in terms of dams,
in terms of pollution.
And a lot of these
fish-- we haven't
paid a tremendous
amount of attention.
What happens is
that you'll put up
a dam somewhere in the Amazon.
And then fish go extinct
that we didn't even
know existed because frankly
the numbers are-- most fish
live in the tropics.
Most Freshwater fish-- the vast
majority live in the tropics.
And they've just been
very poorly studied
and poorly characterized.
KELLY BAILEY: Going
back to the beginning
with the lieutenant up in the
Bronx that you were shadowing.
It really seemed like you had
only just scratched the surface
of the issue with exotic
pet trade in the US.
And then they kind of
went all over the globe.
If you had the option or
perhaps the time, resources,
what would you want to learn
more about exotic pets,
specifically in the US?
EMILY VOIGT: That's a
really good question.
Yeah, I definitely did
just scratch the surface.
It was really crazy.
I feel like there
were so many stories.
And the arowana was the one
that caught me in particular.
But when I called up
this pet detective,
initially, he was telling
me about 1300 turtles
living in this Soho apartment.
And the owner didn't
have room for a bed.
And a guy in Harlem with
a tiger and an alligator
that were best friends
according to him.
The detective was skeptical.
There's just so many stories.
And the truth is it's not a
highly-- during my reporting,
I think I mentioned I
ended up visit-- a man went
to prison in New York City.
Actually, he was sent to a
prison where we put John Gotti
Jr. And also the
Al Qaeda member who
was going to blow up the New
York subway system-- he got
sent to the same prison.
And then there was
this guy who was
in there for having pet fish.
And so I went to visit him.
And he was a pretty sweet
guy-- not to say-- I mean,
he was smuggling them.
KELLY BAILEY:
Smuggling fish, yep.
EMILY VOIGT: He was just
very genuinely enthusiastic
about this fish.
His fish Rosie-- we wasn't
allowed to know where she was,
now.
She was confiscated.
But he believed she was
living in a Texas aquarium.
And he was dying to get out
so that he could go visit her.
This story is-- it's very
strange in some cases--
the criminalization of
some of these things.
I think that there's just
so many stories to be told.
Arowana was my particular
passion, I guess.
The one that I started on.
KELLY BAILEY: And I think you've
mentioned it already, but just
for the audience, I
thought the arowana was
this small goldfish.
But it's quite large, right?
It can get--
EMILY VOIGT: Yeah.
It's the size of
a samurai sword.
But they do sell
when they're small.
So when they're smuggling them,
they would usually be little.
I think that was actually one
of the most basic questions I
lose sight of now.
I've been on this subject
for so many years.
I think one of my first
questions was how--
KELLY BAILEY: How do you
smuggle a samurai sword?
EMILY VOIGT: How do
you smuggle a fish?
Like what do you--
you know what I mean?
KELLY BAILEY: Yeah.
EMILY VOIGT: The guy
who went to prison--
he just had them in a suitcase.
So he put them in plastic
baggies with water.
And then they can make it.
That's how the aquarium
trade ships fish anyway.
Fish smuggling.
But they do get big.
KELLY BAILEY: They do get
they do get very large.
EMILY VOIGT: And
they're carnivorous.
They're called the bony
tongues because they
have these bony tongues.
But they use them
to catch the prey.
So they'll leap out of
the water many feet.
And they'll grab things that
are on low hanging branches--
so even birds, snakes--
most of their diet
was probably smaller
fishes and bugs.
They love cockroaches.
They're huge on cockroaches.
Actually, most of the
people who keep them,
they feed them live
food, which makes them,
I think, a somewhat
difficult pet to maintain.
KELLY BAILEY: I'm not going lie.
It would be a little
bit scary to feed
samurai sword fish live prey.
EMILY VOIGT: Don't Google
arowana eats duckling.
Do not.
KELLY BAILEY: I almost feel
like we should put this
up here right now.
EMILY VOIGT: I wouldn't.
I wouldn't.
KELLY BAILEY: So your journey
across-- this entire story
takes you over 50 different
nations, countless meetings,
and a surprising
number of-- there's
a lot of scientific rivalry,
fish collecting rivalry,
just rivalries all
around in the book.
Were there any specific
events or maybe
relationships that you
came across in your trips
that really stood
out and impacted you?
EMILY VOIGT: Yeah.
So you brought up the
scientific rivalries.
That's true.
I kind of got
caught in the middle
of these to ichhyologists.
I was a little bit
of a pawn, I think.
KELLY BAILEY: You don't
hear that very often.
EMILY VOIGT: A pawn
between ichthyologists.
That maybe the first
time it was every used.
KELLY BAILEY: I don't think
I've ever heard that before.
EMILY VOIGT: So I ended up going
after a new species of arowana
in Myanmar.
And that was probably one of
the more striking experiences
in the book for me
because it was still
very closed at that point.
It was like just
as it was starting.
Actually, the truth is where
I went, it's still closed.
I heard recently from somebody
who came back from-- it's
the southern tale of Myanmar.
That's next to Thailand there.
It's the site of the longest
running civil war on earth.
So even though things
are looking a little bit
up for the region now, it still
is just a very closed jungle.
You can't go there easily.
I think I was surprised
by how many fish remained
to be discovered in the world.
I don't think I'm
giving anything away
when I say that there--
this new Myanmar
arowana-- there actually
was a new species that
is now in the books.
And this is like the
last kind of fish
that you would expect
to find undiscovered
in the modern world.
It's a large fish.
It's a high profile fish.
It was just bizarre.
And the fact that I
could show some interest.
And then it would
turn out to be--
I don't know-- this thing had
been lurking in the jungles all
these years, not being noticed.
It was strange.
And I think it's just indicative
of how little attention is
paid to freshwaters in general.
And it also kind of
reflects something
that's happened in biology.
So if you look back at
the history of biology,
straight back to
the very beginning,
Aristotle was actually--
the father of biology
was a big fish man.
Long story short--
basically, he thought
he would take over Plato's
Academy, his mentor,
after Plato died.
But he got passed
over for the job.
So he was very irritated.
He takes off.
He goes to Lesbos, which
is an island that's
now in the news a lot because
the Syrian refugees are coming
through.
And that's where he
essentially invented biology
by studying the fish.
He wrote his story
on [INAUDIBLE],
which is his longest work.
But it's also his
most neglected.
He was the first person
to sit down and start
to write a natural
history of what was what.
So in the 1950s though, up to
the middle of the 20th century,
biologists use to divide
themselves-- kind of specialize
in one group of organisms.
So you had ichthyologists
who specialized
in fish or people
in birds or earthworms.
It got very specific.
And then came the
molecular revolution
with the discovery of
the structure of DNA.
And the funding
really shifted so
that specialists
in whole animals
started to get pushed out.
And today, it's just--
somebody told me
that ichthyology is a bit passe.
And I think that
that's-- I mean.
That was an ichthyologist
who said that.
So it's an insider view.
But it's true.
I feel like that is-- we're
losing a tremendous amount
of knowledge because
of just the way
that the funding
is structured now.
When the current
generation dies,
there are going to be whole
groups of animals for which
no living expert remains.
KELLY BAILEY: Has
Heiko had any children?
EMILY VOIGT: Heiko?
KELLY BAILEY: Yeah.
Has he had any children
to carry on this--
EMILY VOIGT: Yeah.
Oh, actually, he
has a little girl.
He named her after
his mother-- the one
who took him into the Amazon.
KELLY BAILEY: OK.
So then we at least
have that to go on.
EMILY VOIGT: She is well
on her way to-- it's true.
KELLY BAILEY: To continuing
the trade-- the family trade.
EMILY VOIGT: Important work.
Yeah, exactly.
KELLY BAILEY: So I know,
at the end of your book,
you said that you're
done chasing after Heiko
because there are quite a
few parts throughout the book
where you're just kind
of like-- where is he?
Is he going to show up?
At least for now--
so I'm just curious,
what are you
currently working on
or what are you hoping to
dig your research into next?
EMILY VOIGT: I did spend
a lot of time waiting
for Heiko around the globe.
I think I say in
there, I waited for him
on four continents
at this point.
KELLY BAILEY: It's
got to be a record.
EMILY VOIGT: Yeah.
At this point-- so I
just had a baby recently,
a few months ago.
So I'm kind of focused on that.
But the interesting thing
to me, actually, as I
was writing this.
I was thinking about-- it's
a very male dominated world--
aquarium world.
And especially
the arowana world.
It's a very masculine fish.
And all the hobbyists
that I met were
men with maybe one exception.
And also I was writing
about the history
of exploration and science.
And so also a very
male dominated.
KELLY BAILEY: Male dominated.
EMILY VOIGT: But there
were these two characters
that I think spoke to me.
So one was in the 1850s-- this
Austrian explorer, Ida Pfeiffer
who discovered the lake--
or is often credited,
at least, with discovering the
lake where the super red comes
from in the heart of Borneo.
So she was a housewife.
And she raised two sons.
And she was a piano teacher.
And she just had
dreams of traveling.
And when they were fully grown--
when her sons were fully grown,
she just took off.
She told them she
was going to Brazil.
But she didn't tell
them she was going
to go home the long way around.
So she circumambulated the
globe, which at that time
would be like being
gone for two years.
She was really an
extraordinary woman.
And so I admire her a lot.
And then there's
another model, which
is Heiko's mother,
where you just take
the kids to the jungle, right?
So those things
are all on my mind.
[LAUGHTER]
KELLY BAILEY: So what your plans
for child care for your child?
EMILY VOIGT: Exactly.
I just bring him along.
So the Baby Bjorn in the Amazon.
So actually, right now,
I'm working on an essay
about-- it's much
closer to home.
I was like, I have to write
about something closer to home.
So it's about my bird feeder,
which sounds incredibly boring,
but let me warn you that
pet fish also sounded boring
when I told everybody I
was writing about pet fish.
And they were not.
I live on the 25th floor of an
apartment building in New York.
So it's kind of hard
to have a bird feeder
because if you put it
outside the window,
it's going to fall
and kill people.
So I found one that
goes inside-- the bird
comes inside the house.
And initially, the guy who
sold it to me up in Maine
was like, you're not
going to get any birds.
And we ended up getting
some house finches.
Now, this connects
back to this fish story
because there's a whole
elaborate saga of what happened
with the house finches.
Spoiler alert, a hawk ate
one in our living room.
But it turns out that
the house finches
are an introduced species here.
They were brought
over in the pet trade
from the west coast in
1940, I think it was.
And just a few of them were
released on Long Island
because the dealer knew that
it was illegal to have them.
And he got worried.
And so he released them.
And now there's like a billion
of them on the east cost.
I think that this book certainly
has informed the way that I
just look at every animal now.
And that may be my
next pet trade subject.
KELLY BAILEY: I love this.
You're like the new generation
Ace Ventura Pet Detective,
Emily Voigt.
But I guess I'd love for us
to open it up to Q&A if anyone
out there has questions.
I think there was a--
maybe we have mic.
No, it's over there.
AUDIENCE: Did you ever
feel-- did you ever
feel like you were in danger in
some of the places you visited?
EMILY VOIGT: Yeah.
I always felt like
I was in danger.
But whether I was
actually in-- I
said last night with the
book launch-- somebody
asked the same question.
And I said that,
basically, I was always
worried about something.
So for example, when I had to
get to the heart of Borneo,
I was worried about these
three different things.
People had warned me that
there were Islamic terrorists
in the jungle and
there was an election
about to happen in Indonesia
so that they would potentially
want to kidnap somebody.
So I couldn't even get a travel
agency to help me at all.
And I was worried about that.
I was worried about
the fish mafia
because I could never tell
if it was real or not.
So I'd be talking to
people and wanting
to ask about the fish
mafia, but also wondering
if they were part of it.
It sounds very funny,
but at the time,
I was a little nervous about it.
And the other thing
was headhunters.
So the indigenous people
that live on this lake
were traditionally headhunters.
So I got warned that there was
still headhunting going on.
And that I thought was
totally ridiculous.
I'm like, this is-- it
doesn't happen anymore.
It's this like horrible
characterization
of a peaceful tribe.
I was wrong about that.
So I was always worried
about something.
And I was always
worried about the thing
I shouldn't have been
worried about and not worried
about what I should have.
So that was happening.
But it kept getting worse
and worse in a way, too.
So by the end of the
book, I was like, OK,
I'm just going to go to
the Amazon really quick
and meet Heiko.
And then he sent
me the itinerary.
And it was like the hub of
the FARC activity in Colombia.
And I felt like this fish had
put me through the wringer
by the end.
So the answer is yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
I look forward to
reading the book.
Should I invest money and time
into genetically modifying
the fish so that I can
make my own super red
to sell to people in Asia?
And also, what do
you expect your book
to be received in Asia?
EMILY VOIGT: Oh, OK
These are good questions.
The first thing is-- so Kenny
the Fish might be ahead of you
on that.
And so they are working
on genetically modifying
the arowana.
But it's surprisingly tough.
They still can't do in
vitro with the fish.
So that makes it really hard.
Arowana are super picky lovers.
They insist upon
picking their own mate.
They wont just mate
with any other fish.
Actually, a surprising
number remain mated for life.
So you could.
But I don't know
how you're going
to get the fish into the US.
And I would warn you against
going down this path.
So what was your other question?
It was-- oh, reception in Asia.
I think that there's-- there's
so much interest in the fish
that, so far, people seem
pretty excited about the book.
It's really different
from-- there
are a lot of arowana
books that exist.
But they're all like fish care.
So a lot of times people
will think that I've
written a fish care book.
I think I am, right now,
number one in fish and aquarium
care on Amazon.
I don't mean to boast.
I think we'll have to see
what people think of it.
But I think that they'll
probably be interested
because it's-- the thing about
the aquarium hobby is that
there's something so admirable
about it because these people
know the names of things.
They know the names of species
that-- the scientific names
of species that most
of us have no idea,
and how they fit together
in terms of the evolution,
and where they're
from, and so forth.
And they're really interested
in the natural world
and, and in the
wild, and holding
onto a piece of the wild.
I think that's what
attracts people
to it as much as the looking
like a dragon and the good luck
stuff.
I think it's also a
deeper kind of desire
to connect with nature.
So, yeah.
I wouldn't be
surprised if people
are very interested in
exploring the history of that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Is Asia part of your book tour?
EMILY VOIGT: Is Asia
part of my book tour?
So Aquarama just moved.
So it just moved
from Singapore, where
it's been since like '89, to
Guangzhou because what happened
is, with the rise of the
Chinese middle class--
the arowana became popular
first in Taiwan, then Japan,
and now it's China.
It's all about China.
And so that's had big
consequences on the trade.
And so Aquarama's happening
in the fall in Guangzhou.
So I may be there
with the Baby Bjorn.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Is the fish world--
the black market--
is it a very small world
that everyone knows everyone?
And they're like why is
this blonde lady poking
around kind of thing?
Or is it just big,
and it's random,
and they didn't know about
you before you met them?
EMILY VOIGT: No, it
was the first one.
AUDIENCE: Really?
Really small?
EMILY VOIGT: It was
definitely the first one.
And also, I stuck out
a lot because it's
a hobby that's pretty much
predominantly Asian men.
So I would go to these
fish conferences.
And it was kind of obvious.
And at first, people were
incredibly welcoming.
So it is kind of a closed world.
But the US is also the
largest market for pet fish.
So the fact that
it's a closed market
is not great for the industry.
And so there's an interest
in opening up the US.
And they've been trying to
communicate with the US.
And I have to say
that-- American policy--
it's not exactly informed.
There's not deep knowledge
about the fish that informed
the fact that it's banned here.
Whether or not it should be--
that's a different question.
But they were just
happy to have somebody
who was paying
attention, finally,
who might be able to communicate
the real message of the fact
that these fish are
farmed and so forth.
And so I found that gave me a
lot of access, which was great.
But what was funny was
that as the project went on
for years and years--
like I would run
into them all over the world.
So at a fish
convention in Jakarta.
And then the next fall,
they see me in Guangzhou.
It became apparent to
them that I was just
chasing this fish all the time.
And they would tell
me, what are you doing?
You haven't written
your book yet?
I would say, no, no, I'm
studying your obsession.
And they would look
at me and like--
you should examine
your own obsession.
[LAUGHTER]
They're going back
to their daily jobs.
The fish is a fun
side thing for them--
even the most passionate,
whereas I was like,
I'm going to find this
thing in the wild.
Yes.
I definitely was noticed.
I didn't go under cover.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: So what makes
a fish worth $100,000
versus $10,000 versus
$50,000 in the arowana world?
EMILY VOIGT: So I
know probably more
than I care to about the details
of what makes a fish valuable.
It's really rarity and
the perception of rarity.
So in the case of
the albinos, the idea
was that they don't
come-- that's what's
so ridiculous about
the albinos, too.
Because the normal fish is
valued for its coloration.
And super red is valued
because it's super red.
It's right there in the name.
So if you have a fish that's
born not being red at all,
it seems like it
would be worth less.
But it's totally white.
But it's cool because
it's something
that people don't see a lot.
And it has this
perception of rarity.
And it's really a status symbol.
So if you can have something
that nobody else has,
that's the big draw.
And so that's why the
albino sell for six figures.
In terms of the other fish,
it's how red they are,
it's their scales.
So there's all these things
that can go wrong on the fish.
Basically, you don't want
the fish to look depressed.
And sometimes-- they have these
large eyes, kind of like coins.
When they're in tanks--
I'm not exactly sure why,
but it has to do
with where they look.
They're normally in dark water.
And so I think they're
just looking all over.
And when they're in a
tank, for some reason,
they look down a lot.
They look down.
Maybe they are depressed.
I don't know.
But they get these fatty
deposits up here so
that-- it's almost like-- I'm
going to do a car metaphor
and I'm going to totally mess
it up because I don't know cars.
But when the wheels
are misaligned,
you have to get them rotated
or something like that.
So there's a plastic
surgery that can be done.
There's a whole cottage
industry in fish plastic
surgery now for the arowana.
And I've actually witnessed
some of these procedures.
And there's a lot
of drama because you
have to take the fish
out of the water.
You put it under.
You take it out of the
water and it lays there.
But you've got to get
back in so it can breathe.
So these guys have
to move really fast.
But you remove
the fatty deposit.
And the fish gets an eye lift.
And it looks happy.
The other thing is you don't
want a fish that's PLJ.
That means Protruding Lower Jaw.
And it's really
like-- like that.
Also depressed.
Maybe these fish are depressed.
I don't know why they're having
these different features.
So you can also get a chin tuck.
So if your fish were to develop
a PLJ, you can get a chin tuck.
So these are some things.
So you do have some control
over the value in that regard.
But really, it's the
stuff you would expect.
You want a really red fish.
That's what you're looking for.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
some counterfeit fish?
EMILY VOIGT: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I did.
So the way you
fake an arowana is
by manipulating the
coloration so that it looks
like it's a variety it's not.
So there are these different
pockets of arowana.
I mentioned that green--
you don't want a green.
But there's also different
kinds of gold or different kinds
of red.
So there's something called
the banjar red, which
is not as red as the super red.
But if you keep it in a
certain kind of environment,
it will start to turn redder.
And then, it will
sell for more money.
And then you put it in
a different environment.
And it just gets back to the
sort of orangy hue that it is.
So this actually works
most for the gold.
If you keep a gold fish in
a tank that's totally white,
it will start to kind of
adapt to it's environment.
They don't camouflage
themselves,
but they do manipulate
their coloring
based on what they see.
Actually, this is interesting.
There was a black
arowana I saw once.
And it turned out that-- it
wasn't true of this fish.
But generally,
when that happens,
it's because they're blind.
So they're mimicking their
perceived environment
of total darkness.
That does have some
effect on the coloration.
The other thing is-- I
should point this out.
The fish doesn't take
on its coloration
for three years for the gold
and six for the super red.
So when they reach
sexual maturity,
that's when they come
into their full blush.
And that means that if
you're buying a fish,
they're usually sold
at about six months--
you're buying a fish whose
color you have to guess.
And so I actually went
with a Japanese buyer
to assess-- this is
professionally what he does.
He assesses the babies.
And he tries to guess
what they're going
to look like when they get big.
So you could potentially
sell somebody a green fish,
tell them it's gold.
And then three
years later, you're
gone when it doesn't turn gold.
So that's the kind of
fish fraud and fakes
that I'm talking about.
KELLY BAILEY: Awesome.
Well, I think that's all the
time we have for questions.
But thank you so much for
joining us and telling us--
EMILY VOIGT: Thank
you for having me.
KELLY BAILEY: Yes.
Telling us all about your book.
So thank you everyone
for coming out.
Let's give a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
EMILY VOIGT: Thank you.